the government collects and can collect
and access uh
calls
video calls texts messages they can hack
devices they can hack entire nations
devices
if they want to we have we have the most
totalitarian surveillance legislation of
any democracy in the world
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
director of big brother watch silky
carla welcome to trigonometry thank you
very much it's great to have you on
listen uh for anyone who does not know
who you are uh tell us a little bit
about your background who are you how
are you where you are what has been the
journey through life that leads you here
sitting talking to us
uh i'm the director of big brother watch
we're a uk privacy and civil liberties
organisation
um i've been a big brother watch for a
few years previously i worked at liberty
and started the tech and human rights
program there focusing mainly on
surveillance and that was when the
investigatory powers act was going
through parliament's big mass
surveillance law uh the snoopers charter
um and kind of that's that's my my
journey into human rights campaigning i
mean i've
you know
um i was always a civil liberties um
campaigner obviously growing up in the
post 9 11 years i mean there were really
live debates about civil liberties um
and then in 2013 when snowden blew the
whistle
i felt really compelled to
uh
to to make that part of my kind of
life mission maybe sensitive granules
my focus of work i mean it's so
to me it's very very important for like
a watershed moment
and i started working for his legal
defense fund which then became uh an ngo
that now
looks after whistleblowers and uh
truth tellers including snowden and
chelsea manning and many others
called the courage foundation so i've
been working a lot around surveillance
technology and human rights
as a civil liberties human rights
advocate well we're really excited to
have you on the show because as you know
silky it's a great time
for uh civil liberties in this country
we haven't lost any of them over covid
no yeah everything's great
no no work to do yeah yeah so
could you just give an example of all
the things that have happened over cover
particularly the most important civil
liberties that we've actually lost
oh
yeah how long have you got about an hour
now
um
so
i think around march 2020 we all got
things changed rapidly very very quickly
um even though i think the
machinations of government had been um
preparing for some of the legislative
changes for a bit longer than the public
knew
and so when the coronavirus bill was
published um
it was published about three days before
it being passed um 360 pages
um that is where my sleepless nights
began um because no one was really
scrutinizing it certainly not the
opposition very much
and in there
it's now an act um it's still in force
well over a year later in there
you have the power to detain
potentially infectious people
which can be
in a pandemic anyone there's no kind of
clear threshold there's no detention
time limit there's no clear place you
would keep these people quarantine
centers or anything no clear access to
legal advice just the kind of legal
constructions you don't normally see in
a in a democracy or even in an emergency
uh the power to suspend the right to
protest the power to cancel gatherings
cancel elections a reduction of
thresholds around uh mental health
detention i mean just a really really
broad range of sweeping powers massive
state enlargement with very little
scrutiny and that was supposed to last
for two years
um at that point and of course now we
know
people haven't been shipped off into
quarantine centers for unknown amounts
of time they could be under the current
law that we have which is worrying
enough in itself and protests have
basically been banned
um
but to have those kinds of powers at the
fingertips of government
so readily so easily uh canceling
elections even you know this is
it's really really serious stuff it puts
us in a very perilous
position where all you need is really
you know
a change of breeze and suddenly we're
living in a very very different society
and and let's remember as well i mean
the whole idea of us being in this
emergency yes it's very
terrible i mean
we are in quite mature democracy where
we have the civil contingencies act for
example i mean there are structures and
laws in place that are designed
for
emergency situations
why the government didn't use the civil
contingencies act i don't know there's
never been a clear answer to that it
would mean that parliament would be
scrutinizing what the government is
doing very regularly
instead what they did with the
coronavirus act is basically hand over
the keys to the country uh abdicate
scrutiny
to the government um in in
perhaps most the enabling kind of way
that's where it started i mean obviously
since then we've had literally hundreds
of statutory instruments so small pieces
of legislation that go under the radar
in parliament that have changed the way
that we live that have criminalized
pretty much every aspect of everyday
life
at different points um
but that that that's where it started
and by that i just want to be clear i'm
not saying at all in a pandemic that you
want the government to sit back and do
nothing that they shouldn't be
legislating that we might not need to
have extraordinary measures
but um i don't think we need i don't
think we needed kind of blank check
authoritarian measures and that is
completely what we've seen over the last
uh 18 months and a breakdown of the rule
of law do you think the the public are
less concerned about it than perhaps
they ought to be because we've been so
terrified about covid that a lot of
people feel like well any measure to to
help with that is necessary uh we we
certainly see people you know people
were talking about how anyone who goes
abroad and then brings back covert
should be you know sent to jail for 10
years or something
like people say no just fibbing on the
form you can go to jail for 10 years
right yeah wow so
so p
i guess what i'm getting at is we can
complain that it hasn't been properly
democratically scrutinized and i think
that's a very important point which i
want to come to a bit later but on the
broad side of it i think is it fair to
say the public generally haven't really
been that concerned about this
it's a good question
i think that
the public my sense is that the public
is quite divided i think
particularly people who
have been
living in fairly comfortable situations
making sourdough for the last
year
are not that concerned they might be
used to working from home they might not
be economically hit as much as everyone
else they might not be the kinds of
people that are targeted by the police
when they go out
but i think that
there are
probably millions of people who are
actually completely alarmed and freaked
out by what's happened over the last
year
and who don't have a voice and haven't
been given a voice because the media has
been doing the government's work for it
and you might again you might say there
are very good reasons for that but there
hasn't been any balance and even on like
really simple matters like how democracy
and politics work um
you know i've been watching
incredulously political correspondence
fail to even acknowledge
basic massive changes in the way that
parliament works or total lack of
scrutiny total lack of opposition
um the way that timing of introducing
some of this legislation has been so
completely cynical
to
um basically
disempower parliament now compare that
to what happens when the same
broadly the same government tried to
disempower parliament over brexit
it was top of the news it was the
biggest news story
everyone became aware of the importance
of of of of parliament parliamentary
procedure the power of mps we have a
parliamentary democracy you know we
don't have a completely executive
dominated democracy and that was a
completely different type of of of
coverage um and brexit too was important
because it was uh you know
it was the will of the the people the
pandemic is important but to say have
some have some balance and i think part
it doesn't also doesn't help people who
are losing trust in the establishment
uh and in institutions because they feel
deliberately
silenced or and not represented whether
that's on the media or actually whether
it's online as well where um
you
i mean
i could go on forever about this but
about how you know the severely uh
shrinking space for the sorts of things
you can say about the current situation
on facebook for example we'll get into
that don't worry about that yeah we'll
get into that but didn't you find it
surprising you know the whole point of
an opposition is to challenge the
government
if anything they were even more
authoritarian
yeah even more authoritarian and also
um
i think the general
kiersten's general approach seems to be
you won't be able to put a paper wedge
between me and the government and kind
of like sit back let's see if they fail
maybe then i'll pick up some votes that
seems to be the kind of strategy um to
me i just want to be clear by the way
big brother which is a non-partisan
organization i'm actually personally a
non-partisan person as well part of the
reason for that and i think part of the
reason that a lot of people are
disillusioned with politics is we're
back in the realms of a kind of
um
you can't a kind of bipartisan consensus
i mean there there's a growing consensus
between the two main parties this is
what we had kind of for a lot of the
blair years as well
um and then just this whirlpool of
authoritarianism at the center of it
where citizens are losing out and i
think
i think it's a really bad strategy
for for any political party
it's deeply deeply unfair to the people
that they claim to represent
and it's bad for british democracies
actively harms democracy um and it has
been left to rights groups and ngos like
us to do the hard scrutiny work and
you're basically delivering scrutiny
work to mps and saying please look at
this just you know don't have to do the
work yourself just have a look at what's
actually going on speak up for the
people who care about this for example
under the under the coronavirus act um
the power that i mentioned to
detain potentially infectious people
unsurprisingly has never been used
lawfully to detain potentially
infectious people it's been used as
another stick to beat people with and
it's been used for 100 unlawful
prosecutions and we know that because we
campaigned as soon as it was passed to
say the cps needs to be
uh reviewing every prosecution that's
happening under this power because it's
so extreme
and they've found that hundreds of
people have been unlawfully
uh prosecuted not a single lawful
prosecution
and we have lobbied parliament to remove
those powers for obvious reasons we've
never had a law that's been used only
ever
unlawfully to
you know jail people yeah and
it remains in in in power now we it's
very hard to motivate the opposition to
even
say anything about it do you think
there's been a watershed moment with the
murder of sarah everard where suddenly
people realize that hang on
you can't even attend you know a vigil
without the police coming in and
literally kneeling on people's necks
particularly women and there was that
very striking image do you think the
tide has turned she was kneeling on her
back and the officer was kneeling on on
her back yeah um
i think it it it obviously shook a lot
of people
and the optics of it were absolutely
awful i was there as well um
it was pretty bad yeah the the the
atmosphere uh the vigil was uh you know
the way the police were dealing with it
was typically
uh kind of brutish really for no for no
of obvious reason
um
but but actually
people have been treated like that at
protests for quite a long time
and you know i might really care about
that particular one but there are other
ones if you defend the right to free
speech you defend you defend it
agnostically for whatever it is the
individuals are speaking about there had
been plenty of other protests that had
been brutally pleased where people have
been
arrested and now facing prosecutions the
prosecution's now coming through the
courts and no one was willing to speak
up for them very few people we did but
very few few people were willing to
speak up for them
so
actually one of the things that we did
was um look at all of those mps who came
out after the vigil and said
that was terrible policing we should
defend the right to protest
and said
ask them to sign a joint statement
saying we think that there should be an
exemption for the right to protest in
the lockdown regulations which many of
them hadn't said before we'd been saying
this is really important you can't ever
criminalize
uh protest
um
and then we released it uh on a weekend
when there was a massive anti-lockdown
protest
uh which i don't know that all of the
mps had maybe clocked i'm not saying it
was like a deliberate thing um but i
think it was really important that you
know if you're defending the right to
protest you defend it for everyone um
and and also you defend it because you
have to bear in mind that
as in that case you never know what's
around the corner so you never know if
there's going to be a sudden change of
circumstance or event or some kind of
outpouring where people want to express
themselves are you really going to
criminalize those people you're going to
give them a criminal record whether it's
going to ruin their career or limit
their life opportunities just because
they want to hold of placards and say
something they cared about
but that is literally
those protest restrictions remain in
place today and i'm aware there's big
protests this weekend and i'm sure more
people will be arrested and prosecuted
unfortunately well you talk about uh we
don't know what will happen in the
future and how rules and regulations and
laws are going to be used and i think
that's such an important point because
we are also not party political i mean
we think they're all bloody useless at
the moment uh but at the moment well
yeah for a very long time now but
particularly at the moment but
nonetheless i think a lot of people
might be willing to kind of allow the
current sort of
you know people would i think see it as
a sort of softer version of what a
conservative government could be
potentially so boris johnson isn't
someone people think is gonna you know
start the fourth right in the uk
but but you are putting things in place
where there's no democratic
accountability things aren't being
checked things aren't being vetted
extraordinary powers are being given
they're being misused as you say uh
no legal use of a law would seem to me
that to suggest that it's a bad law
right
but do you think that people
just not thinking ahead in terms of what
the consequences of this will be down
the line
well i think i guess um part of the
luxury of living in a
relatively stable democracy is that
people get complacent
but not everyone is again i mean i do
actually think there's been a bit of a
sea change i can only say from my
perspective i mean big brother watch
we're still a really small organization
but for us we've had a massive surge of
support the phone never stops some
people just want to talk and sometimes i
find myself spending just a couple of
hours on the phone just talking to
someone who has actually just suddenly
become quite freaked out by the
situation that we're in even if that's a
journalist or a member of the public or
sometimes a member of parliament i mean
there really are members of parliament
who are
freaked out by
what they are seeing from their
perspective
some of whom aren't speaking about it
completely frankly in the public domain
um and so there's this kind of but this
is one of the things that really worries
me about the current situation that
we're in is this kind of like
uh
it's it's kind of a bit north korean the
way that people are self
censoring
and so even though there might be broad
acknowledgement that
we're in a very perilous position things
have gone too far
uh
there's been a breakdown of some of the
the the basic architecture of what makes
us a democracy
um
when people are witnessing
uh you know
you know the 90 year old man that got
thrown in the back of a police van for
going to a protest
things just start
triggering people to
really really acknowledge that we've
gone perhaps beyond a point of return
but people won't talk about it and even
within social circles um a lot of you
know kind of
um you know
ordinary
liberal
social circles these are difficult
things to talk about
um or even a mine you know it's it's
a lot a lot of people don't want to talk
about you you know you want to be you
this is odd kind of sense emergency you
want to be seen as like a true believer
in the national programme and the
clapping and everything i mean there's
something that's a bit too
um you know i like the energy as much as
anyone but there was the whole you know
banging the pots and stuff there is
um
there's something
a bit disturbing about this level of uh
self
censorship
yeah i mean i didn't take part in any of
that because i'm a miserable gift but
she just laughed like yeah probably yeah
i mean there's there's no
there's no dispute about that
i just find this so so worrying and i
and
i really like your opinion on this do
you think the government going to give
back some of these powers
because i look at them and i go
will they they don't like giving up
power any of these [ __ ] yeah
they will never give back powers never
um
and i suppose that's why i see i don't
think we can really understand the
context that we're in now without
understanding the post 911 context right
that completely changed everything
and to this day has changed everything
and all we've ever seen since then is a
ratcheting of powers
which is why
it was like you know the privilege of my
life to work at liberty because liberty
uh did so much in the post-9 11 years
under shammy to challenge some of those
successes
um of of government um power but we do
still broadly live under
all the counter-terror legislation um
you know
so so much change mass surveillance um
and so it's going to be the same i think
now we've got a
emerging concept of bioterrorism uh the
idea that we
perhaps will walk around society with
health passes
um increasing surveillance generally
the idea that we kind of now unlicense
from the states that each of us has a
potential not only terrorist but
biohazard
and the there's this whole new raft of
state controls that are uh going to be
um
deemed as acceptable or even necessary
or even that would be unsafe not to have
them
um and so how how do you peel back
that you have to peel back the whole
narrative
i think we i mean obviously it's our
mission to try and um get the government
to give some of those powers up
but it won't happen by itself so yeah
people need to get involved now and take
action now and realize their own power
and influence now which everyone does
have and i think is underestimated
because this is going to be a marathon
and
it's almost too late i think
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
you raised one thing that i really care
about very strongly and
this is the vaccine passport thing and
people should be making their own
decision about the vaccine i think if if
people are at risk or whatever they
should be definitely taking and that's
my opinion uh for younger and healthy
people i think it's a different
calculation but it doesn't matter where
you are on the vaccine the vaccine
passport thing if
i think people need to understand the
implications of this so but there's also
another dimension to this which is the
ministers like michael gove and others
said to us there were no plans to
introduce vaccine passports and this
wasn't true was it no
i mean yeah this is the the other kind
of worrying facet of this is that um
there
have been
bare-faced and not even really
effectively concealed lies consistently
um and
and a kind of choreography
through
the
the uh building of this
growing authoritarianism
um
and so yeah contracts were going out uh
from
uh late last year to build
uh vaccine passports or covered
passports i mean the way that they're
looking at it now is it will be vaccine
or test
result or antibodies
um
so while that's going on people are
going on television and saying we have
no plans to do this while handing out
millions of pounds in contract not just
television but
stating on record in parliament
that we have no plans and in fact nadine
zahari said in fact we we urge
businesses not even to think about it
whilst they're setting up focus groups
to talk about how how it's going to go
down with the public and
starting to invest
lots of money in in building them
i think there's an element of
of of cock-up there really i mean i
think i don't know if nadine zaha we
actually knew what was going on
within his own brief um but there was a
time in politics where you would maybe
resign after that
but now no one resigns over anything the
age of shame is over completely just
right in the fridge yeah you go away
yeah
um so yeah and now you know right up to
where we are now months later um the app
the the
vaccine passport is now a feature of the
nhs app
um and it says on the privacy policy
that they envisage using it domestically
this might be useful for access to
domestic events
whilst um in public and in parliament
saying we're really not sure about
whether whether we're going to do this
it was very finely balanced you know
we're really looking at the facts we're
doing a
consultation etc etc um but all the all
the architecture is there and actually
michael gove said this week um no matter
what decision is made they're going to
build the architecture because they
could at some point spring it up and
that was his reflection on what happened
in israel as well because they had the
green pass
which is now being rolled back and there
was you won't hear about it in the press
here but i'm in touch with people there
there was a lot of pushback to it um
and
he similarly said
um but it might be reignited at any
point so um
yeah there and that's the idea with test
and trace as well you know um it's 30
plus billion pounds of public money on a
whole new
architecture that can just be used you
know that that's not a temporary thing
that's not for an immediate uh the
immediate situation that's a long-term
plan and and this is the thing i mean it
happened after 9 11 as well
in that
when you know there are certain projects
that some people
in
government have always wanted to pursue
and uh then
an emergency can give you an opportunity
to
very quickly with less scrutiny and with
very few limitations on public spending
just start to change everything
and there certainly are all sorts of
visions within government about the ways
to use technology and uh
change the way that we live well what
are your concerns with the vaccine
passports because some people might be
watching this going well look it's
making us safer we can know who's got
covert who doesn't you know uh maybe i
haven't done a good job of explaining
like what's the what's the argument
against vaccine passports what are you
concerned about what should people
watching this be like oh wow okay i
hadn't thought of that well we'll talk
about covered passports more generally
if that's okay because that's where the
government wants to wants to at least
start so test vaccine or antibody status
there are problems with with each i mean
first of all it's not going to make
anyone any safer people are going people
who want to get vaccinated are going to
get vaccinated people who don't want to
are not going to
we don't yet have
mandatory vaccines in this country so we
will see each other we will mix
the whole idea that you can create this
theater around certain events and places
where it's like a clean zone and you've
only got the green ticks are allowed in
and somehow that's going to change the
whole public health situation it's not
what it might do is alleviate liability
on those businesses and on those events
because they can say we've we've done
this although one thing that was
interesting that michael gove said
yesterday is they're not going you know
one of the
concerns we were raising is how does
that affect staff if you work for
example at a football stadium and you're
a steward
does that mean now as part of your work
you are forced to either have a vaccine
or have a medical test in order just to
go to work
um but he said that they're not going to
put the obligation on
uh staff
which makes the theater even more
ridiculous because you're not going to
have only green ticks and the whole idea
of that stupid how do you get to the
football stadium we get there on the
coach with everyone else or the bus or
the tube where you're packed in with
you know spreaders or you know whatever
we now are
um
so
i think the risk is that this it's an id
system it's a digital id system
and back when you had the um id debate
after 9 11
it was treated as kind of a future risk
like imagine if you had to have your
health records on there i could imagine
if people started asking to see your
health status or you know had hiv on
there or something these kind of things
that come with a lot of stigma and
control
but that's the starting point for this
is that you have your health records and
you show them to people
and you carry it with you
most places you go or you know you're
deemed a different class of citizen so
this is id cards
and digital id cards on steroids
population wide
and it will become
[Music]
a tool for discrimination for division
it will be used as as as i'm afraid yet
another stick to beat people with you
know there will be
certain people will ask other certain
people to see their past
um and uh i think that will make us into
a very very ugly
checkpoint dystopian society
do you think it's good they're gonna
pass it through they're gonna pass the
legislation to enforce this do you know
what i think
i think there might still be something
to play for and i think um watching
michael gove in his evidence session
this week
um
he was
he actually always looks quite inflated
but he was quite deflated
it was quite deflated in the way that he
was presenting it he didn't seem to
really
i i i don't know what's going on behind
the scenes but i get the sense i i mean
it's no secret i think within cabinet
this is very controversial idea
um and uh anyone with any political
sense knows they're gonna get hammering
going for it i mean
uh
there will be serious serious kickback i
think and i think they'd be making
definitely a grave grave mistake i mean
i think as
i think the conservative party forgets
uh
they are especially where this kind of
electoral shift has happened they are
kind of unlicensed from the working
class
um you know this is not a
they really shouldn't assume that this
is a new permanent state of affairs uh
nor should they assume that the
failure of the of the opposition equates
to their success
and i think um a lot of it stems from
the kind of anti-establishment
uh sentiment around brexit yeah and the
sense of being betrayed and all this
kind of thing
i can't think of anything more
establishment more controlling
than
voicing digital ids and covid ids on a
public that has
a
historic
long-held aversion and skepticism
towards the idea
in fact it was one of the reasons that
the tories got into power in 2010 they
promised to scrap id cards um
so i think there are people probably who
are thinking about the political
ramifications of this also the fact that
there's no real point there's going to
be no real benefits either in public
health terms or political terms
um and i do get the sense that now that
there's some
um
it's like the wind's been taken out of
the sales of the idea and i think that
is down to our campaigning and uh
everyone who's speaking out against this
in
you know rights groups media
the protests
i think that's that's really visible and
tangible
if we continue to do that it might just
be
that we won't actually see this come to
fruition
however if we're not successful in that
then um
they're going to introduce
them for
covert passports for large events large
ticketed events like sports music
festivals
all venues of a certain capacity
and he also said he would do that
through a statutory instrument so it's
not even primary legislation in a normal
sense which means you can't
mps can't amend it it's like an all or
nothing
my understanding of where the numbers
are on there there'll still be a vote my
understanding on where the numbers are
is that they would have a hard time
getting that through parliament
but it all comes down to labor actually
i mean the numbers are much easier well
that's not sure
the numbers are much easier to do on the
on the conservative side because i think
they don't have the confidence of their
own party
the question is will
will labour oppose them and certainly
the labour back benches will but whether
the front bench will uh remains to be
seen it's just very much on the fence at
the moment i think what kia did say
which is right is it fundamentally
unbritish
well we've done quite a lot of things
that fundamentally i'm british in the
last year i guess the takeaway from this
is everyone should write to their mp i
think about this is that
i think it has a surprisingly more
impact than than people think i mean
often when we're uh lobbying mps they'll
say i just don't have emails in my inbox
about this
um
all right well let's make sure there's
some emails in the inbox
so let's move on a little bit we've
talked about government action uh i
actually no longer think government is
the most powerful institution that
exists in the world
it's me and you mate that's it's just me
and you
she's laughing more than any and more
than any point during the interview so
there we go um i actually think that the
biggest powers in the world are the big
tech companies uh at the moment they
control who gets to be president who of
the united states and what they can
influence that they've shown their
willingness to do that um
and uh in terms of the issue of covid we
have seen that for example uh the lab
leak hypothesis the idea that the covert
19 came from a lab in china initially
was dismissed as a conspiracy theory
anyone who said anything about it would
be banned from twitter banned from
facebook their youtube channel will be
deleted etc now that issue's coming back
is potentially the truth about what
happened now we don't know but the
conversation wasn't able to be had and
it's only thanks to a lot of people
bravely going against that that we we
seem to have that conversation now we've
had a conversation on our show with a
doctor about some aspects of covered 19
medical microbiologist which was taken
down by youtube uh and youtube was very
heavy uh in its censorship of people who
had a view about covert 19 that was not
the the particular view that was
supposed to be allowed at that moment in
time and then three months later
suddenly all of that actually turned
about the efficacy of masks for example
right
so
what is the situation with regards to
big tech where are we like they just it
seems to me just deciding what we can
and can't talk about now
yeah completely um it's such an
inversion inversion of
um
everything that the internet promised to
be this big space for
um people to speak without barriers um
and you know speak directly to power and
increasingly it's becoming like a
controlled government controlled
actually speech zone because even
finding a distinction between some of
the big tech companies and governments
is becoming increasingly hard and again
this is another
extraordinary thing that this government
is wading into with a new um bill the
online safety bill
whereby um they they have invented a
a new a category of
content that is harmful
anything that's harmful needs to be
regulated on the internet or taken off
the internet even if it's lawful
and so part of what the um
tech companies are doing is preempting
that
um
they can see this regulation coming
and they're preempting that part of it i
think is driven by kind of reputational
concerns there's this whole
god only knows why but there's this
whole category of journalism at the
moment it's like we found a bad thing on
the internet
it's like what really
all those billions of people you found a
nasty one in there like that that's
become a whole category and so they're
very responsive to that
um and yeah now
we're kind of completely through the
looking glass in terms of
where the
uh the shape of the restrictions online
um
i know you have felt the brunt of that a
bit i've actually felt the brunt of that
uh myself um you know perfectly
reasonable ordinary stuff um that you
can be
banned online for for saying um
and i think especially given the
proximity of some of that recently over
coronavirus ii uh the
pr wishes of the chinese government
is pretty chilling
um
yeah i mean i know ian beryl's piece on
um
unheard which just merely sort of
questioned the efficacy of the world
health organization um
investigation into the origins of covid
was marked as as false on on facebook
um
yeah and now of course they're they're
they're rolling back well who'd have
thought it you know you
facebook is
should never be big tech companies
should never be the arbiters of free
speech and also that the whole concept
of free speech has never ever been and
should never be
the accepted consensus of
government authorities or
intergovernmental authorities i mean the
whole point of free speech is it allows
ordinary citizens to speak
their
sorry
truth their opinions
i [ __ ]
to give their views to power yeah yeah
um and actually now what they're saying
is
you can say what you like if it if it
agrees with the government's view on
things
um
and i don't even think that that um it's
it's crazy isn't it why is this so
accepted i mean i i i
it's like a big alarm bell moment i
think it should be for all of us that
there is a shrinking space
to speak freely and especially given how
much we spend our lives online
um the shrinking space to think freely
as well and how it's actually shaping
the kinds of conversations we're having
when we're offline
you say that and look i'm gonna
give the argument that people always say
look they're private companies they can
do what they want if you don't like it
go somewhere else what is your response
to that well um
i mean
the idea that this isn't
de facto censorship is
uh crazy i mean of course it is i mean
they they are um hosting the
conversations of billions of people
there are more people on facebook than
the populations of many many countries
around the world um and just with one
policy change they can affect what
literally billions of people can say to
each other so this is a very serious
type of censorship
yes they're private companies but um
part of what i'm worried about actually
with the online safety bill is that
because the government is saying is
creating
these expectations on them that they are
doing regulation and
censorship of lawful content if it's
basically undesirable
harmful
um
then yeah we're no longer looking at the
free will of private companies we're
looking at uh the total integration
where we heard this before of the
private and public sphere into a system
that controls what people can say
i can't think of anything
more dangerous more ludicrous than that
and also creates a barrier to entry so
even if you are
a new
uh company that wants to create a new
platform pilot
then then you've got all of these
regulatory um barriers that mean you
know you would need a a team far bigger
you need an infrastructure of a size uh
that you clearly can't have as a
fledgling company so there's a total
barrier to entry as well as this
monopolization
do you want to promote your business to
an intelligent audience who don't need
to know your pronouns to buy your
product here at trigonometry we have
over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and we frequently get over 3
million views a month that's a lot of
new customers for your business we speak
with some of the biggest guests from the
world of politics economics journalism
arts and entertainment all of them have
spent at least one month in the gulag so
you don't have to and we'll match your
product to the perfect guest for you
american sponsors will be matched with
american guests and so on that way you
know your advert has the best possible
chance of getting to the right people or
as we call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing trigger
pod dot co dot uk and we'll make your
nightmares come true
it's it it's so worrying isn't it and it
cheered you up then yeah yeah you have
well i'm miserable anyway and you've
just made me more miserable so thank you
very much for that
but let's look at sort of what what can
people do
because what we're doing is we're
analyzing the problems but what do you
think are going to be the solutions
moving forward
um
i mean
obviously i think that
joining with or supporting organizations
like us like big brother watch um
is important as pop certainly part of it
because we're tracking this we're seeing
we're scrutinizing what's going on we're
lobbying on these bills we are trying to
bring more to public attention certainly
to political attention and producing
research and analysis around this and
litigation where necessary as well so
we're currently crowdfunding uh to
bring a challenge to covert passports if
they go ahead
we just won a challenge on uh mass
surveillance post snowden i mean so we
we do we do litigate as well
but i think
i think that's i think that's really
important kind of finding your crowd and
you know finding like-minded people who
are concerned about these things i think
also this may be a very hard thing but
actually even just talking about these
issues
uh with people there is definitely and
also to your member of parliament of
course because um it's often people who
are the most kind of disillusioned who
realize uh the kind of
uh problems with the political system
they don't want to engage with it i
completely empathize with that i
understand that
but it's a necessary thing to do
especially in this kind of you know
dangerous moment that we're in um
we have to be ringing alarm bells you
know wherever we can particularly with
people that hold their brains on power
or at least who should do
um but i think actually even talking
about these things is is really
important i think the kind of
um
spiral of silence among a lot of um you
know
otherwise liberal people is a real
problem it's a massive problem and i i
don't think you know spaces like this
i bet there's a lot of i bet you've had
emails from people that say
i've been looking for something like
this so i'm really glad you had this
conversation haven't seen it elsewhere
or just somewhere you can actually think
and speak freely about some uh issues
that otherwise aren't discussed very
much in the media or
um
among the chaturani more generally yeah
those are some of the emails we get we
get a few others as well uh but actually
you bring up the political point and i
know that you are not partisan and we
try and stay away from picking sides as
much as we can we're just trying to
operate on basis of principles of what
we think is important
and you mentioned that there's a silence
seemingly particularly on the sort of
liberal side of the spectrum and i find
that very odd i found it very odd when i
was a comedian started saying well
there's a bit of an issue with free
speech going on people immediately
assumed that i was right wing yeah and i
don't i have no idea what your politics
are frankly it doesn't even interest me
we're talking about this issue to me
this is not a political issue it's a
it's an issue of like the west for
centuries has been trying to get to a
point of enlightenment where there's
certain things that we all understand
are important for a liberal society
uh how is that that link been made
between
freedom
and being like a bigger of some kind
like how did that happen
it's a very very good question isn't it
um
i don't know and it's um
yeah i was looking back to
um you know the aclu
in the us and uh they've changed their
tune lately haven't they yeah there's
been some big there's some big changes
over there i mean i see a really
important organization they do loads of
really important work um but you know
they
made their reputation through doing some
of the hardest
free speech work you can imagine
they defended the rights of neo-nazis to
march through
a jewish area of uh
in the us and to do these neo-nazi
marches
you wouldn't actually be able to do that
under uk law so already this is more you
know this is um look it's under the kind
of american model of free speech uh it
would be definitely incitement
all sorts of offences that could fall
under here
but it forced um
um
the aclu um and many of their advocates
who are jewish to um put forward a very
very compelling argument about why they
thought that was it not only in
principle but in practice the right
thing
and there is a long jewish tradition of
defending the right to free speech and
and human rights and civil liberties
generally obviously given uh modern
history
and
we've come so so
far away from that um they were i think
absolutely vindicated in the campaigns
that that they did they showed
themselves to be truly agnostic truly
dedicated to the principles of free
speech
um it eventually defused the situation
um
and
like you say if you if you believe in
kind of post enlightenment idea of
rationality how does rationality work
why do we have free speech because we we
trust in individuals in people and
publics
to
explore information
deal
with it and that
through free and fair access to
information rationality will prevail
um the the the enlightenment idea was
not it was obviously in fact a kickback
to the idea that the elites controlled
the information for the benefit of the
public we've just gone back about 500
years
because we're back at this kind of view
that the elites need to control the
information for the benefit of the
public
and i think there's perhaps a problem
with maybe um elitism in some liberal
circles certainly in rights
organizations i mean they are generally
you know middle class um you know
organizations but they simply don't
trust ordinary people with information
as you saw a lot of this rhetoric around
brexit
this kind of idea of um you know
whatever your views on it again but the
the very dominant um we were on the
right side um the very very dominant
idea
um of um
like an anti-brexit was that you have
these like uh poor brutish people who
can't properly understand information
they're just duped um and you actually
had a bit of that after the most recent
election as well uh you know these
working-class people don't really know
you know
you know they're just kind of
duped you know idiots
this kind of like a amorphous group of
dumb people who who make mistakes
um unsurprisingly you know that that's
not going to pay off politically but
also it's just not true
um and i think the the the damage that
is
i i think it's a real
i think it's actually a travesty
that there is such an abandonment of
free speech principles that that kind of
philosophical underpinning of free
speech and why it matters
on the left it's really sad and the
other kind of practical thing about it
um
is that there's just
uh part of the reason maybe you see less
from rights organizations is there's no
there's no there's no funding for free
speech work anymore
and that's this is maybe interesting to
only people inside my world but it might
help to explain to people
why you see less of it when you have big
funding organizations a lot of groups
rely on them
to
to do their work
and
no one's funding free speech stuff
there's a lot of funding for
disinformation misinformation type work
do you think that's maybe because to
just offer a little bit of a counter
the internet has opened up a massive can
of worms when it comes to mass
communication so
50 years ago if someone was standing on
the street corner banging on about how
vaccines are actually microchips and
whatever
you know people 20 people would walk
past probably all ignore that person and
there was no harm done nowadays david
ike says something people are burning
down 5g mass the next day
there's a bit more of a consequence to
speech when it's done online because of
the multiplication factor of it because
you can reach millions of people and
because let's be honest the internet
does incentivize
the spreading of misinformation because
it it's it's exciting it's like it's
extra spicy food or extra flavorful like
people want it they want to hear the oh
the secret answer to all that actually
was you know the lizards or whatever
i don't know that the consequences of
speech
have changed i mean people made the same
kind of arguments when uh the printing
press was invented but the printing
press did allow for mass communication
in a way that previously wasn't possible
yeah
yeah so people also had this kind of
panic about you know
the pros having access to information
and
the yeah the lack of control lack of
kind of centralized control over it i
mean the thing about the internet is
that if you truly democratize
information
um you can
then
especially if you're in a kind of forum
environment you will have at your
disposal
lots of different views and
interpretations of what you're reading
and seeing you can do your own research
you can find academic papers you can
find
journalism unheard views whistleblowers
yeah but that isn't how most people
consume the information most people go
on youtube and go oh there's a thing
here about how the vaccine's all
[ __ ] i'll click on that i'll watch
that and they won't then go to a forum
or anywhere else to check out the
counterfactuals and the counter
arguments that's kind of the argument
that you know i do have some sympathy
with which is the internet has created
unique challenges around this this issue
because people don't just you know not
everyone is going around seeking all the
different points of view on a particular
issue uh you know
you go on on a mumsnet forum about the
trans issue there's only one view being
represented there right uh and i'm not
saying it's the wrong or right view but
it's only one view and increasingly
everyone is kind of stuck in the echo
chamber of their own opinion and i think
that that's maybe where i have some i
have some understanding of the issues
that the big tech companies are trying
to address do you do you see what i'm
getting at
uh
no okay
no i don't for why um i agree that echo
chambers are a problem i think that's a
massive problem um and that people are
curating their
often increasingly radical world views
by deciding who they hear from on
heavily curated timelines and also you
know for example even when you go on on
twitter hardly anyone uses it
chronologically anymore so twitter is
pushing you the things that they think
are going to be most attention-grabbing
sometimes even people from you that
you're not following you know they're
trying to feed you things that are going
to
maintain your attention because that's
where the money
is and the same happens across all the
platforms it's not just there so i think
the echo chamber is a real problem
um much more than the availability of to
speak freely and to access information
freely which let's not forget is a
fundamental right and for very good
reasons
and i think the reason that those echo
chambers are not the subject of scrutiny
is because that's the business model and
that's where the money is right if there
was a proposal that said i'd be really
interested if we just would have tried
this thing first of all for a year
ban micro targeted advertising
ban um
that kind of granular data collection
from individuals
and see what happens and i think half of
those problems i think more than half of
those problems would just fall away so
what you're really saying is
they're pretending to try and fix the
problem the problem is echo chambers but
they are pretending to fix it by
restricting what people can say if they
just allowed the echo chambers not to
form in the first place we wouldn't have
the issue i think echo chambers are a
problem i mean also wouldn't say that um
it's not it's not to say
free speech comes with problems for sure
like i'm not saying that uh videos that
are deliberate falsehoods uh etc are not
problematic of course they are
but
the belief in free speech is that the
best way to deal with them is by having
a free and open environment
um and by having forums where people can
speak and challenge if you don't have
that if you don't have debates and if
you push people into
uh kind of their like deeper darker echo
chambers where they can't be seen and
heard it's not going to change their
point of view it's going to make them
feel marginalized and ignored and it's
not going to expose them to the
challenges they would otherwise
encounter
and moving on i saw a very very
interesting article about one of the
head bods at microsoft worrying about ai
and the fact that we're essentially if
we don't actually challenge the progress
that we're making and we let technology
run away with itself we're going to be
in a dystopian society very very quickly
and far sooner than we originally
thought
to me that was one of the head guys at
microsoft what do you think about that
elon musk has been warning up the same
thing for a long time as well yeah
there's a lot of you know people who
work in the tech sector some of the um
you know where you find a lot of
preppers as well you know people who are
um
worried about the direction of travel
and how bad things might get and the
kind of tech dystopia that awaits most
of them are still willing to make some
money out of it before they decide to
you know pack a get a backpack and and
move on um but yeah i mean already um
you know what some of our work has
looked at is how that's creeping into
uh how that's affecting citizens here um
early uses of ai
so you see ai in the criminal justice
system already
there was a system used by durham police
where
when someone was suspected of an offence
they could be put through this
ai tool
that would assess how likely they were
to reoffend this is before they've even
been
prosecuted by the way
um and it's true we don't even know if
they've offended yet yeah essentially
yeah from a criminal justice point of
view yeah and there was this there's
data fed in about the individual
judge whether they're going to reoffend
and then judge
are you going to prosecute them or put
them through to a rehabilitation program
and
we were then looking at the
types of data that were being fed into
that and and that's often where the
problem i mean there are obvious
problems risks with ai
but i mean i think you have to start
from the point of what's the ai built on
often it's masses of personal data um
that kind of feeds the beast
and
um so they were using
um
postcode data
so you know this postcode would say
something about you um and also a what's
called a
geodemographic uh segmentation tool
they're very popular in government now
it's basically every single person in
this country has a profile given to them
by this tool
there's more or less built on your
postcode
and
millions of pieces of data that ranges
from gcse results electricity usage
ratio of gardens to buildings to kind of
get a sense of like what kind of class
and category of players about 60 odd
different
codes that you can be and so this stuff
was fed in to judge
someone's life outcome basically um i
have a film about something like that
minority report something yeah yeah
there's so many things like that now um
in the criminal justice system in
particular we've got facial recognition
now that the police want to use facial
recognition cameras
um
yeah that we
in local councils well one of the things
we've been analyzing um
recently we've got a report coming up is
about the use of
automation automated decision making and
big data in the welfare system uh once
you apply what kind of profiling and
processing are they now doing there
great stuff i mean exciting the future
is bright for us it is bright it is and
it just seems we're on this relentless
march whereas before 15 20 years ago
you'd go and see something like minority
report and you'd be like oh that's
that's an entertaining slice of
entertainment isn't it oh yeah i'll just
walk into the real world but more and
more it just seems that technology is
going at hyper speed
and it's running away from us
yeah it's it's it's a classic story of
power you know that i think
anyone if you're civil liberties or a
rights advocate you have to
scrutinize power and look where the
sites of power are and try to
um
you know make sure there's a healthy
balance between
citizens and those sites of power
whether it's governments or
technology companies and so on
um but i think one one of the things
that is obviously
you know not great about my line of work
is that often
because of the situat when you
acknowledge it and i think this is why
so many people are in denial or
cognitive dissonance about the current
situation that we're in when you when
you really take stock of it and
acknowledge it it's quite daunting and
the overwhelming sense is fear and fear
is just a very
low vibration thing to uh you know to
dwell on
so
uh you know that's a problem and i think
we have to get beyond that i think i
think what's perhaps exciting about the
moment that we're in as much as it is
extremely challenging is that whenever
you see a force an action there's a
reaction um and i do think you know
people talk about the tech lash
there's some of that i think that there
will be
probably a delayed but there will be a
response to
um
you know the harder and faster the pace
of authoritarianism that we're
experiencing right now
we will see the same
uh kind of reaction to that and how
that's going to play out politically etc
is something to watch but i do think
wherever there's a vacuum
um that vacuum political vacuum that
will be filled um like we can see over
the last 10 years with some of the
anti-establishment kind of political
movements
um you know we have to make sure those
vacuums are filled in the right way but
i think that they will be and that's why
i think anyone who
is uh motivated by this moment
what we're currently going through as a
country and and more broadly
who is motivated to
uh
build you know actually have a say about
the future especially if you're a parent
you know a lot of people are worried
about the kind of world that their kids
are going to grow up in would do
something about it um you know the
future is absolutely ours for the taking
and and
and we just have to claim it and i i
think that would be an interesting thing
to to be part of and watch over the next
few years well it's a lovely note to end
the interview on uh we always finish uh
with our final question which is what is
a one thing we're not talking about but
we really should be
um well since we had this week our our
legal win in the
uh
legal challenger gate
we had a legal challenge against mass
interception
after snowden blew the whistle in 2013
so we've just done eight years of of a
legal challenge
um i think we it's important for
everyone to know if they don't already
if
last decade didn't get it through
that even in the uk
we are now living in an environment of
mass electronic surveillance
and our own government spy on us what
does that mean practically when you say
mass electronic surveillance is your
phone listening to you right now um
the government collects and can collect
and access uh
calls
video
calls texts messages they can hack
devices they can hack entire nations
devices if they want to we have we have
the most totalitarian surveillance
legislation of any democracy in the
world in the uk
and some of the most
advanced capabilities we've seen over
the last few decades
how you've had environmental activists
race equality campaigners
environmentalists being spied on um by
by their own government and and
sometimes with with very negative uh
impacts
um
that is
a big chunk of the battle that we have
to fight and i would like to see a bit
more uh that to kind of register on the
political spectrum a bit more um but
meanwhile i would say to everyone use
signal
and we've gone back into being depressed
well you're back where you belong but uh
we're gonna do a couple more questions
for locals only in a second but uh uh
silky uh thank you so much for coming on
the show it's been a pleasure having you
on i have no doubt we will be calling
you again very soon probably from a
prison cell yeah
we could be meeting in prison
but um tell everybody what they can do
how they can get involved with big
brother watch uh where they can find you
and your work online
thank you well uh we are
bigbrotherwatch.org.uk
on twitter at big brother watch
and we have some micro sites now as well
i think one that people might be
interested at the moment is stop vaccine
passports dot co dot uk
excellent all right well thank you so
much for coming and thank you for
watching at home we will see you very
soon with another brilliant interview
like this one if we're not in prison uh
which we probably will be but anyway
keep following the channel and we'll be
streaming uh live from belmont see you
soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below